these next artists brought a distinct
humanity to their characters and their
stories their dexterity and ability to
provide dimension and strength to their
entire castes the impression they left
elevated each film each experience here
the nominees for performance by an
actress in a supporting role mary j
blige
Allison Janney I Tony
Lesley Manville Bachelor
[Applause]
Laurie Metcalf ladybird Octavia Spencer
the sacred water
[Applause]
and the Oscar goes to Allison Janney
[Applause]
and nomination for Alex and Jay
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
I did it all by myself
okay nothing further nothing further
from the truth
thank you to the Academy my fellow
nominees you represent everything that
is good and right and human about this
profession you were all extraordinary
Steven Rogers look what you did look
what you did you're a brilliant writer
thank you for the gift of Levana I did
not see this coming you did you give new
meaning to the word friend to my eye
Tonya family the Magnificent Margot
Robbie the fearless Craig Gillespie a
cast and crew and bird that elevated my
work to Tom and Brian neon thirty West
my my team Janney Leslie severs Chris
Henze Alana Rice Karen Sanfilippo we've
been together a long time thank you for
all of your work Joanne Woodward I want
to thank you for your encouragement and
generosity that gave me the confidence
to think I could pursue a career in
acting too my mother and father J my
family my family our friends the staff
at gotta you know who you are I love you
and this is for how you're always in my
heart thank you very much
[Applause]